-Donald Trump was intimately
involved in plans to seize
voting machines and stay in
power in the waning days
of his presidency.
Also, and I'm sure this is just
a coincidence,
a bunch of his white House
records were shredded
and had to be
taped back together.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look, you guys,
I don't want to
talk about Trump
and I shouldn't have to.
Normally when someone stops
being president,
they go away and then later they
open their library
and you say, "Damn, he got old."
and that's it.
But Trump never went away for a
second.
So we here at "Late Night"
are on the coo-b.
we've spent the last year or so
chronicling the brazen
criminality of Trump and his
weirdo henchmen
who tried to over throw American
democracy
and are almost certainly gonna
try to do it again in 2024
as we call them the...
[ Laughter ]
Of one of them, God forbid,
ever buys a Cadillac
we'll have to
start calling them the...
[ Laughter ]
But the point is we can't just
forget that Trump
and his movement tried to
overthrow democracy.
And they are, as we speak,
actively laying
the ground work to do it again.
Believe me,
I desperately wish he'd vanish
and we'd never hear from him
again,
but that's clearly not the case.
He keeps hinting that he's gonna
run in 2024.
And as nightmarish as it is to
even contemplate it
there's a good chance he's gonna
be the Republican nominee.
We have to be clear-eyed about
his criminality.
Now some of you doubters out
there might be saying
"Not so fast Ron DeSantis
looking pretty formidable
and I'm sure he will continue to
look that way,
until he gets on stage with
Donald Trump.
because he's just doing a knock
off impression of Trump
And given the choice, people
always choose the real thing.
I mean, who do you think would
win a battle of the bands --
U2 or four unknowns from Dublin
doing U2 covers?
[ Laughter ]
One more time for U2,
now make some noise for Us Also!
[ Irish accent ] Uh, we probably
should've gone first.
[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, even their Irish accents
are gonna be bad.
Point is, Trump won't go away
and he might run again.
And if he does,
he'll almost certainly try to
finish what he started with his
attempted coup last time around.
And the GOP's either actively
complicit
in that slow-moving coup
or ignoring it
so they can spend their time
throwing a racist temper tantrum
over President Biden's pledge to
appoint a black woman
as the Supreme Court justice.
-Joe Biden's promise to choose
a black woman
as his Supreme Court nominee
is divisive.
It's un-American.
Racial preferences,
sexual preferences.
First of all it's illegal.
-The way that the president has
handled this nomination
has been clumsy at best.
It adds to the further
perception that the Court
is a political institution like
Congress.
-The fact that he's willing to
make a promise at the outset
that it must be a black woman,
I gotta say, that's offensive.
-Right. Right if --
-Black women are what,
6% of the U.S. population?
He's saying to 94% of Americans,
"I don't give a damn about you.
You are ineligible.
He's saying, "If you're a white
guy, tough luck."
If you're a white woman tough
luck, you don't qualify."
-Hey, man, what the [bleep] you
talking about?
There have been more white guys
on the Supreme Court
than there are at a Patagonia
clearance sale in Connecticut.
Normally to see that many white
guys on the bench,
you'd have to watch
March Madness.
Out of 115 Supreme Court
justices,
108 have been white men.
You're a white guy who went to
an Ivy League school
they call you in the day before
graduation and say
"Alright, you want to write for
'The Simpsons'
or be on the Supreme Court?"
[ Laughter ]
White guys complaining about not
getting on the Supreme Court are
like Patriots fans complaining
about the last three years.
"When's it gonna be our time?"
Anyway, back to the...
Personally, I might be less
focused on the various
investigations into Trump,
if Trump himself
were less focused on them.
I mean, he talks about them
non-stop.
And the New York Times reporter,
Maggie Haberman, wrote recently
that Trump's aides have always
signaled that if
the investigations progressed,
that he would
run for president again.
Trump is so obsessed with the
various investigations
into his personal and business
affairs he ranted about them,
at length,
at one of his truckless
monster truck rallies
over the weekend.
-They are viciously and
unconstitutionally using
the federal, local, and state
governments to prosecute
and silence politicians like me.
For years, they've been going
after my company.
Many years,
using every trick in the book
in an attempt to literally,
if they can, put me in jail.
They've subpoenaed more than
9 million pages, big company,
of documents.
And virtually every deal I've
ever done hoping to find
a mistake, an error, misspelled
words, a comma out of place.
Or anything else
that they can find
that might be just a little bit
wrong.
All these "never Trump-ers"
working full-time
in the prosecutors office
to get Trump
because they couldn't do it
before because they had nothing
after all these years, can you
believe it?
How do you like my life?
You think I have a good time?
Actually, I guess
there's something going on
because I do have a good time.
-I'm not sure you do have
a good life.
If you did, I don't think you'd
have to drag your supporters out
twice a week to clap for you
like some kind of
geriatric Tinker Bell.
[ As Trump ] Folks, if you clap
for me, I'll come back to life
and we'll put Hillary in jail
for the computer thing.
If you only believe.
[ Normal voice ] You sound like
the guy who insists
he has a great marriage,
but also thinks we should
start doing poker night twice a
week.
But, yes, I agree,
there's something going on.
In fact, I guess that's the
official medical diagnosis
from looking at a CAT scan
of your brain.
Well, Mr. Trump, I've looked
over the images and there's no
easy way to say this,
there's something going on.
My last doctor didn't see
anything.
Is that the same doctor who said
you were in great shape?
What's your point?
Oh, [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
Also, could we go back to this?
-They've subpoenaed more than
9 million pages, big company,
of documents.
And virtually every deal I've
ever done hoping to find
a mistake, an error, misspelled
words, a comma out of place.
-I don't think they need to hope
to find a misspelling
or a comma outta place.
Looking for misspellings in a
Trump document is like
looking for Waldo in a book
called "Only Waldos."
Most of your tweets look like
you typed them left-handed
in the middle of a sword fight.
In fact, Trump's paranoia about
what he calls mistakes
in his personal and professional
documents apparently
manifested itself
in very real ways,
because when the National
Archives handed over a trove
of documents from the Trump
White House to the committee
investigating the January 6th
insurrection,
some of them had apparently been
torn up and taped back together.
-The National Archives,
in a statement,
confirming that some of the
documents that they received
from the Trump White House that
were of interest
in the January 6th select
committee
came to them ripped up,
shredded up.
And they were forced to tape
them back up
before they were given to the
January 6th select committee.
Now, we don't know exactly which
documents these are,
but we do know that the former
President Donald Trump
has a habit of tearing up
documents,
that, in some cases,
former White House staffers
had to tape together.
This was a practice that went
back to as late as 2018.
So, it is significant that this
was something that continued
right up until the end of the
Trump administration.
-It doesn't surprise me that
Trump treated official
presidential records the way
the rest of us treat
credit card offers from Discover
or the way I treat
autograph requests from my
wife's niece.
Get lost, Becky!
[ Laughter ]
She puts them on eBay
and then complains to me
when they don't get any bids --
she's no angel.
[ Laughter ]
I would say shredding documents
is an obvious sign
of someone's guilt, but I'm sure
Trump does it with everything.
[ As Trump ] That's another
3-under round for Donald Trump.
Tear this up for me
into a million pieces.
[ Normal voice ] Also, let's all
spare a thought
to the federal employee who had
to tape all of Donald Trump's
presidential records back
together,
just getting Ziploc after Ziploc
full of confetti
soaked in hand sweat and then
trying to figure out
which words to put together to
form sentences.
Piecing together Trump's notes
is like fishing
a bunch of magnetic poetry out
of a garbage disposal.
But it turns out Trump had good
reason to rip up the evidence to
all the crazy [bleep] he did in
the White House.
Every day we find out more about
just how close he came to
pulling off a full-blown coup.
Recently we learned that his
administration has drafted
several executive orders to
seize voting machines
And then this week,
we learned that Trump
was directly and personally
involved in those discussions.
-The New York Times reporting
that 6 weeks after the 2020
race, which he lost, Mr. Trump
directed his attorney
Rudy Giuliani to ask the
Department of Homeland Security
if it could legally take control
of voting machines
in key swing states.
-Donald Trump's advisors drafted
more than one executive order to
seize voting machines
during the former president's
final weeks in office.
There was one order for the
Pentagon --
we had known about that --
but overnight CNN reporting on
another for Homeland Security.
-Trump also tried to persuade
state law makers in Michigan
and Pennsylvania to use local
law enforcement
to take control of the voting
machines in those states
but they also refused to do so.
Trump then moved onto the
military.
-Man, Trump tried everything --
Justice Department,
Homeland Security,
swing state law makers,
even Rudy Giuliani.
of all people, I can't believe,
and yet, also I can believe
that he had Rudy call the
Department of Homeland Security.
Although, who knows with Rudy.
It could've been a butt dial,
which he's done before for real.
In 2019 Rudy butt-dialed an NBC
reporter.
And it makes sense because Rudy
always looks like he just
sat on his phone
and accidentally made an
emergency call.
9-1-1, what's your emergency?
There's a voice coming from my
pants.
Sir, sir that's me.
My, my penis?
One of the terrifying reasons
Trump's coup didn't work
is that Trump is a lazy moron.
He tried every avenue
he could think of
and he almost pulled it off.
if he'd been more disciplined
or more diligent,
he probably could've done it.
But that's why we can't just
move on and forget about it
because either Trump or someone
even more ruthless
will come along and try it again
in 2024.
And the GOP is already laying
the groundwork
for the next coup as we speak.
Meanwhile, Trump is --
-Using every trick in the book.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.